[Música]
al menos 23 personas murieron el pasado
viernes intentando llegar al enclave
español de melilla desde marruecos sin
embargo algunas organizaciones que
trabajan sobre el terreno hablan ya de
37 sus cuerpos esperan a ser enterrados
en fosas cavadas a toda prisa por parte
de las autoridades marroquíes sin que se
haya sido identificados estos cuerpos o
se hayan realizado autopsias
organizaciones como naciones unidas su
amnistía internacional piden a las
autoridades una investigación
independiente exhaustiva sobre el
incidente más grave ocurrido en décadas
recordemos también que el año 2005
murieron al menos 13 personas a manos de
la policía marroquí y española y
enfermeros mi 14 murieron ahogadas otras
15 personas en la playa de tarajal a
mientras los policías españoles
utilizaban contra ellos material
antidisturbios para entonces hablar
sobre este problema que ocurre en estos
dos enclaves españoles en marruecos
quiero saludar en ese momento a papá
brown dog experto en migración humana y
derecho internacional actualmente
la ong de federación africana españa
gracias papá por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 estas
ciudades autónomas de ceuta y melilla
suponen las únicas fronteras europeas
terrestres en el norte de áfrica qué
implicaciones se tiene esto en cuanto a
migración digamos se refiere y todo lo
que está ocurriendo y todo lo que vimos
la tragedia que vimos el pasado viernes
papá
muchísimas gracias en primer lugar por
invitarnos desde el canal 24 ha sido
realmente un placer aquí estamos en
valencia españa ha sentado porque lo que
hemos hecho solamente es usar uno de los
elementos el derecho a la movilidad
humana porque el derecho a la movilidad
humana son tres derechos el primer
derecho es el derecho a emigrar el sobre
un derecho es el derecho a no emigrar
porque dentro de nuestros propios países
tenemos todo lo que necesitamos para no
olvidar el tercer derecho el acabamos de
james joyce el derecho a migrar y
asentarse por eso estamos aquí asentados
áreas de valencia españa y para que
puedo responder rápidamente a su
pregunta creo que es muy importante
porque se puede si tenemos tiempo auto
buscarlo en el aspecto del derecho
internacional porque esas dos ciudades
se encuentro en mares internacionales
pero para ir directamente en lo que ha
sido
quería del viernes pasado a las 6 desde
las 3 de la madrugada es muy simple
porque la gente van de viaje por avión
otros por tren otros como ellos intentan
venir a españa con los medios que tienen
estos chicos el 37 que han sido
asesinada hay también que sumar 30
333 heridos y dos muy grave y hay que
sumar también mil detenidos en esos mil
detenidos han sido trasladados en
autobuses desde
en la ciudad fronterizo con melilla
hacia rabat hacia marruecos son casi 500
o 600 de kilómetros de viajes imagino
ahora mismo que hay muchas veces
compañeros que quieren morirse
ahora bien y sienten que estos chicos
realmente
no estaban buscando mejorar sus vidas lo
que hacen muchas personas todo lo
contrario a veces chicos han sido
realmente el producto de las
desigualdades que estamos viviendo de la
pobreza que se ven viviendo porque
siempre dice que áfrica es un continente
rico pero los africanos son pobres es
una paradoja
yo quiero entender que esas personas es
guerra lo ha dicho también en el louvre
un virus porque marroco está corriendo
para intentar
enterrar
a esas personas
africanas asesinadas por el mero hecho
que la mente no quieren son dos
elementos el primer elemento es que en
el hospital donde están no hay cámaras
frigoríficas
hay dolor insoportable de 37 personas
ahora vienen al área de esto para hacer
entrar sin potencia sin identificarle
nacionales nacionales
lo interrumpo porque quiero preguntarle
entonces ante el pedido de
organizaciones como naciones unidas
también hablo josep borrell de la unión
europea diciendo que se hagan digamos
una investigación exhaustiva y teniendo
en cuenta que va a entrar a estos
cuerpos sin ninguna investigación previa
cómo van a lograr determinar realmente
las causas por las cuales murieron y una
investigación transparente de este caso
es perfectamente corazón en el canal de
educar refrán si tiene razón porque
realmente nosotros lo que queremos desde
la federación unión africana españa
porque hasta a charly michel que es el
el presidente del consejo europeo lo que
ha dicho es apoyar la gestión migratoria
de españa porque esos cuerpos realmente
está más pendiente porque ahora mismo as
o podemos decir que se ha parado sea
parar un poquito o lo que quiere hacer
porque es el problema también de la
externalización de las fronteras hay
acuerdos bilaterales entre españa y el
reino de marruecos que lo que hicieron
son acuerdos de cooperación y critica
duramente hay y hay que decirlo
directamente hay mucha pasta que han
sacado porque solamente entre el 2007 y
la unión europea ha gastado 2 mil
millones de euros para blindar sus
fronteras digo dos mil millones de euros
para frontex 2000 millones de euros para
su seguridad para quienes esos chavales
quizá
van a intentar desviar la opinión
pública por lo tanto es importante para
nosotros tener la posibilidad de
colaborar con ese medio para que no se
han enterado y dejarse solamente un
número gratificación porque ellos tienen
padres tienen hijos tienen familias las
familias tienen el derecho de saber
realmente cómo murieron además
pensamos que la primera reacción que
debe hacer debería hacer el presidente
del gobierno de españa no haber tirado a
pérez sánchez porque counter gays uno
represente representa una inscripción es
transmitir sus condolencias a las
familias gloria estas personas a la cual
a los líderes africanos que hasta ahora
no hay ni una reacción de estos líderes
africanos es un habitué les duele
realmente como africano asentado aquí en
europa de ver que no hubo reacción y si
pusiera digamos por el claro porque sacó
entraron este el core por es el cuerpo
negro de ese cuerpo de áfrica no es sólo
pueden ser realmente es
lo contrario papá qué pena lo interrumpo
es que ya se me acaba el tiempo para
esta conversación que como lo digo
podemos estar pues hablando por
muchísimo tiempo más porque realmente
hay muchas aristas en todo este caso es
definitivamente como también usted lo
decía pues por lo contrario el
presidente de gobierno español pedro
sánchez pues simplemente elogió lo que
hizo la policía en ese lugar gracias por
estar con nosotros o papá un abrazo